-Welcome back, everybody!
Thank you. Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
He is one of the hottest
new Marvel superheroes,
and he is hosting
"Saturday Night Live" this week.
His movie "Shang-Chi
and the legend of the Ten Rings"
is on Disney+.
Please welcome Simu Liu!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What's going on?
-Good to see you, pal.
-Good to see you.
It's good to be here.
-Come on, look at that!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Mwah!
-They love you.
Simu and I are about to compete
in a virtual-reality game
called "Beat Saber."
-Mm-hmm.
-Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns
using this --
using laser swords to slash
targets to the beat of a song.
And we'll see who can get
the highest score.
Sound good?
-Sure. Yeah, whatever.
I've never seen that before
in my life, but let's do it.
-Yeah, here we go.
[ Light laughter ]
All right,
I'm gonna get over to the --
All right.
See you soon, bud.
-Good luck, buddy.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-All right.
This is rad.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go, man!
[ High-pitched laughing ]
Yow!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh, wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
BTS, right?
-BTS!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
Okay.
-The clapping is distracting me!
-I'm not distracting you.
I'm cheering you on!
I'm being your hype man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
♪♪
-Oh!
I'm getting tired!
How long is this song?!
[ Laughter ]
-As long as it takes, Jimmy.
Keep going!
-My arms are exhausted!
-Oh, my God!
-Are you kidding me?!
-It's a key change!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
End this song already!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my God.
You -- Here, here.
Oh, my -- here, please, please.
-Appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That was, uh...
-Simu, "Heck, back in my day,
we used to just play video games
sitting on the couch."
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
-My favorite -- My favorite part
was when you just did --
you'd hop to the side
and you just did this, like...
this little twirly thing.
[ Laughter ]
-That's how I dance
when I go to a wedding.
I just go, "Oh!"
That's my jam.
I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Simu Liu.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's your turn.
Get into position.
Put on the headset.
-Okay, so I'm here.
-Good luck.
-What's happening?
[ Audience cheers ]
♪♪
-What's going on?
Am I doing it wrong?
-Watch out for the walls!
-Am I --
[ Laughter ]
Watch out for the walls!
-Okay, I think I'm starting
to get the hang of it
a little bit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
you're crushing this.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?!
Yo!
Dude!
Oh, my gosh!
Wow!
♪♪
Have you done this?
Oh, my gosh!
-Am I doing it?
I still have no idea.
What's going on, Jimmy?
There's so many things.
-Are you a big
Billie Eilish fan?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good luck!
Keep going!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got this, buddy!
Yo!
♪♪
-I'm ready for it to be over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, Simu.
Simu.
All right.
-Oh, man.
-[ Laughs ]
Well done -- Well done, buddy.
All right, now look.
Do we have the points?
I got 100,105.
Simu, you got 109,527.
You are the champion!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't mess with you.
-Oh, my God.
But I feel like you
went on forever. Like, your song
was like 10 minutes long.
[ Laughter ]
-Simu Liu, everybody.
We're talking
to Simu after the break.
Come on back.